[MUSIC PLAYING]
IKAI LAN: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to another edition of
"Google Developers Live." My
name is Ikai Lan.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Arun
Nagarajan here.
IKAI LAN: Just before we get
started, I want to tell all of
our live viewers that the
Hangout button will
unfortunately not be
working today.
We love seeing you, we love
talking to you guys, but it's
not going to be working,
so don't keep trying.
I'll remind every five minutes
for the people that are
jumping on a little bit later.
It's going to sound like a
broken record, but I'd rather
let you guys know than to have
people sit there and try to
jump in and not be
able to do so.
So why don't we go ahead
and get started.
We've got a--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Let's do it.
IKAI LAN: --good show
for you guys today.
First off, I've got
two announcements.
We have two special shows.
They're going to be live, but
we're going to post them onto
YouTube.com/googledevelopers.
The two shows are--
Arun's doing a really
good one tomorrow.
It's going to be about
Salesforce.
And I'm going to be doing
one about triggers.
So why don't you go ahead and
tell them a little about the
show you're doing tomorrow.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
A little plug.
So Salesforce.com, as a lot of
you guys know, is a very
popular cloud-based
CRM system--
IKAI LAN: Is it?
Is it now?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: --a lot
of businesses--
IKAI LAN: Yes.
Salesforce is very popular.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And us being
a cloud-scripting language,
there's a lot of synergy there
that we figure we should do a
GDL about, show you guys how
you can connect, both send
data up and also receive files
and data back and show it on a
spreadsheet, put
it on the site.
Lots of cool stuff.
So hopefully, you'll join us
tomorrow and get a sense for
what that's like and how easy
it is to get started.
And hopefully, you'll walk away
with some recipes that
you can try out yourself.
IKAI LAN: And I will definitely
be watching that
show, partly because
I think I'm on it.
So I will be here tomorrow.
So if you aren't completely sick
of the two of us, join us
either live tomorrow at--
I think it's either 4 o'clock
or 4:30 Eastern--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Check
our G+ page.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, check either
our G+ page or
developers.google.com/live.
I think it's either
4:00 or 4:30.
I'm pretty sure it's
4:30, though.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: We'll
be there.
IKAI LAN: It's an hour long.
I think it's 4 o'clock, yeah.
It's a little bit longer than
our normal shows, which are
half an hour.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Actually,
I just remembered.
It's 3:00 to 4:00 Eastern.
IKAI LAN: There you go.
Yeah.
Check the schedule.
I'm sorry about that.
We change time zones so much
when we're talking to people.
And I'm doing a show next--
I believe it's next Tuesday--
again, check
developers.google.com/live.
It's about triggers.
This one is a little bit
more beginner level.
But a lot of people use Apps
Script, and you're used to
spreadsheet functions and
working with Docs.
But what you don't know is that
you can schedule things.
You can have code be executed
when spreadsheets are open.
Not a lot can happen when a
spreadsheet's open, but you
can do things on
certain events.
And I'm going to be talking
about how to do this as well
as some advanced techniques
of things
you can do with triggers.
For instance, one thing that a
lot of people run into is, how
do I make a script that
basically runs forever?
Well, it's kind of
difficult, right?
If you know your script's
going to run for
two hours, you can't.
Because there's a timeout
on how long your
script can run for.
However, if you change triggers,
it is more or less
possible to simulate this.
And it's a little bit
more durable, too.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Another
use case is workflows.
IKAI LAN: Workflows, yes.
We have a script that
we're working on.
It's a little bit secret.
No, it's not like anything
world-changing or anything.
I'll be talking a little bit
about that and how I'm using
clock triggers to work with
documents that are essentially
destructible documents, which
you give them out, and after a
certain amount of time,
they go away.
So we'll be talking about
that next Tuesday.
Just check
developers.google.come/live.
Now again, I know I'm going to
be repeating myself a lot.
Do not try to join
the Hangout.
It's not going to work
for you guys.
They were very, very
sorry about this.
And hopefully, we'll have this
working at some point.
OK, I think that's
it for the plugs.
Why don't we go ahead and let's
go and get started.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Didn't
you want to say
hello to someone special?
IKAI LAN: I did.
The someone special
is Rudy Lehman.
We met you at the Los
Angeles Hackathon.
This was on November 13.
We ran into Rudy, and he said
he watched the show
religiously and I
was like, wow!
We have real fans.
Rudy drove all the way from
Phoenix-- either drove or
flew-- from Phoenix
to Los Angeles--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It was
quite the trip, yeah.
IKAI LAN: --so he could
participate in our Hackathon,
which you gave me a pretty good
segue into talking about
the Hackathon.
First off, if anyone is watching
from Los Angeles, hi.
We had a great time
meeting you guys.
Hope you liked the office.
I'm really sorry about the
confusion at the beginning.
But I'm really glad how
the event came out.
We had some really great demos
where people came out and
built things like a conference
room scheduler, am I spending
too much of my life
typing meanings?
Just a lot of really
good developers.
And we're really happy
to have met you guys.
I know that you met some
cool people, too.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes, some very
creative folks that come from
all walks of development some
folks that work for the city
of LA, some folks that work in
schools, some folks that are
professional programmers that
just code all day and wanted
to come and go to the
Hackathon as well.
So really interesting to get the
diverse set of developers
that use our product and get a
lot of first-hand feedback.
I know Drew, who was one of our
core engineers that was
there, he really appreciated
meeting a lot of
you folks as well.
It was really worthwhile for us,
and hopefully, it was for
you as well.
We'll probably do a follow-up
blog post just highlighting
some of the apps that we got to
know and discuss a little
bit about what we learned
at the event as well.
IKAI LAN: The food truck
guys, I hope
those guys are watching.
I really liked many
of you guys.
We had these two guys
that worked for
a food truck company.
And I was looking at their
keyboards, going, what are all
these rubber things
on their keyboard?
And their laptops-- let's be
fair-- they were really
disgusting.
And they told me, we're
really sorry.
We work for a food truck.
There's food everywhere
all the time.
It's getting all
over the place.
But these two guys came out.
They built a system
for hiring and
distributing employees around.
Very, very cool.
I was happy to meet them and see
that they were doing cool
stuff through Apps.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Exciting.
Shall we do release notes?
IKAI LAN: Yeah, go for it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
Cool.
IKAI LAN: I don't think
there's anything super
earth-shattering in these
releases, but we're spending a
lot of time to really
just improve the
polish of Apps Script.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
Great.
I think the last Office Hours
we held was on the 14th.
And since then, we've actually
had two releases, one on the
21st and another one earlier
this week on the 28th.
Yesterday, actually.
A few things that are
worth noting.
There was an issue around
the lock service.
So if you tried to gather a
lock too quickly and then
release it subsequently, some
of the releases were not
getting queued up properly.
So you would run into
an issue where you
could not get new locks.
It would timeout, and it
would just say that you
don't have a lock.
So we fixed that issue.
We re-allowed the ability to
have multiple addresses
in the reply to.
IKAI LAN: Yay!
I didn't know you
could do that.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You were able to
do that, and at some point,
there was a mistake, and
we could only do one.
And the third one that we
fixed on the 21st was
something with the
editor, actually.
So if you have a library that
has HTML content in it, the
auto-complete stopped working
in the editor.
It was not a runtime issue.
It was sort of an authoring
development issue.
But nonetheless, it was painful
for our developers,
and we went ahead
and fixed it.
And then the subsequent
release, a bunch of
enhancements as well.
We did an enhancement to allow
you to retrieve the BCC
address for an outgoing
email message that you
may have access to.
So when you're parsing an inbox,
if you authored an
email or the person that's
running the script authored an
email, you could find out the
BCC address for that message
and then do interesting
things with it.
A long-standing issue with
the On Submit trigger not
returning the right values
in the event callback.
So when you got the data
range, it was returning
incorrect top and
bottom indices.
And that caused a
lot of problems.
I think this one is probably
starred quite a bit in the
issue tracker.
So we're happy to report
that that's fixed now.
IKAI LAN: Keep starring
those issues.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
IKAI LAN: Keep starring them.
Please star them.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
The next one was around
the auto-complete of
XML document function.
This one was a little bit more
about the authoring aspect of
things and discovering
of what's capable.
And then we updated the tree
widget, the UI app tree widget
to have some handlers
for opening and
closing of those nodes.
That's one of the UI
app widgets that
we've recently improved.
So those are some of
things we've done.
Take a look at these.
They're on the developers.googl
e.com/apps-script site.
And if you just scroll to the
left on the bottom, there's a
section for release notes.
So keep an eye on it.
And if you keep an eye on it,
you'll notice that we do quite
a few releases.
In November, we probably
averaged a release a week,
even with the holidays
and everything.
And we'll keep them coming, and
at some point during the
holidays in December, there
will be a freeze.
But hopefully, we'll
have a couple more
good releases to report.
IKAI LAN: Right.
Again, the freeze is only a
production push freeze.
It doesn't mean that we're
stopping work, although--
you're just full of
great ideas today.
No, we're going to continue to
keep iterating and building
features and improving
the product.
So again, to find these,
you can either go to
developers.google.com and click
through to apps-script.
Or, me personally, I just like
to search for Apps Script
release notes.
That brings me to something
we forgot to plug earlier.
For those of you watching,
no Hangout today.
Really sorry.
But we've caught a couple good
blog posts, too, recently.
Google Apps Developer blog.
Is that right?
What is the exact URL?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You
said it right.
Googleappsdevelo
persblog.blogspot.com.
IKAI LAN: Let's just tell
people to search for it.
If you look for Google
Apps developer blog,
you'll find the blog.
We've got a couple pretty
good codes.
We got one from Romain, who
always, always gives us these
great posts.
Revevol is the name
of his company.
Hopefully, I'm pronouncing
it correctly.
But they're doing a lot of very
cool stuff with apps in
Apps Script.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
This one is a kind of
a utility script
that anyone can run.
It's a really good example of
the power and simplicity yet
the effectiveness
of Apps Script.
So I think it's, all
in all, just a few
dozen lines of script.
But it allows you to set
reminders in a spreadsheet,
and then get email reminders,
and then be able to respond
and lots of unique things.
You may not use it, but at
least you'll find it
interesting and useful to adapt
for your own purposes.
IKAI LAN: I've been
working with Apps
Script a lot this week.
I don't know what it is about
this week, where I just had
this whole backlog of things
I wanted to build.
And I've been really happy
in the environment.
There's this thing that I
thought would take me an hour
to do, and it ended up
taking five hours,
which isn't a bad thing.
It just means I was totally
lost in this thing.
I forgot to eat lunch.
And I forgot how awesome it
is to build stuff within
Spreadsheets.
Go to Spreadsheets, Tools,
Script Editor.
Because with Spreadsheets, you
automatically get this UI
where you can display data
and manipulate data.
Now, the bad thing is that when
I wrote the script, I
told the clients that were
going to use the script.
And again, I'm not
doing consulting.
It's Google employees.
I told them, don't edit anything
in the spreadsheet.
Don't touch this stuff.
So that's kind of the downside
of Spreadsheets is that if you
write a program outside of Apps
Script that accesses the
database and someone goes in the
database and just starts
messing with all the values.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You
don't want that.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
And what I'm working on right
now is kind of a pretty cool
thing with the URL shortener.
It's because we're trying to
figure out, how are you guys
finding us?
How are you guys finding
about the show,
finding about the blog?
We want to know.
We want to figure out if it's
coming from Twitter, Google+,
the blog, YouTube.
We just want to look
at these things.
So I'm working on a script,
and hopefully, that'll be
something that I can publish
or at least talk about in a
future show or article or
blog post or something.
But let us know your comments.
We really should have a feedback
box somewhere.
People can drop and send--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You can provide
feedback on the
documents that we have in
the developers site--
IKAI LAN: You can-- preferably
documents, right.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's a little
more contextual to the
help content that we have.
Obviously G+ is a great
way to find us.
Google+ is a great way to find
us and leave us comments and
questions there.
Yeah, we should probably
have a--
IKAI LAN: Yeah, for now, what we
want to do is, we're going
to start planning out the
shows for next year.
So if you have any ideas for
things you want to see or
things you want us to
do, drop us a line.
Who has the easiest
email here?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I think you.
IKAI LAN: Really?
Really?
OK, yes.
Maybe.
My email is--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Four letters.
IKAI LAN: --ikai@google.com.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: His
first name.
IKAI LAN: Alternatively, you can
also email Kallion, who is
gkal@google.com.
Four letter email addresses.
Love this.
Email either gkal@google.com or
ikai@google.com for ideas
about things you want to
see in future shows.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I think there's
a couple other blog
posts that I want
to talk about--
IKAI LAN: Oh, yeah.
Go for it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: --the
one that Eric did.
Eric Koleda.
IKAI LAN: Yes.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It
was actually a
really good blog post.
IKAI LAN: Forgot
about this one.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Underscore.js,
which is a great utility belt
library that most JavaScript
developers that I know use it
for a node js application or
a browser-based web app.
Whatever it is, it's one of
those utilities scripts.
It's sort of like what jQuery
is for dot manipulation.
Underscore is for just general
programming niceness, so array
manipulation, finding things,
slicing maps, just the
shortening of forEach function
or paradigm, things like that.
It just makes it
so much easier.
And it's got a great name,
great way to access it--
underscore dot function name.
It's got a templating syntax,
I just found out.
So Eric wrote a great blog post
about how you bring in
these third-party open source
applications into the fold in
Apps Script by using the library
capabilities, both for
client side and server side
JavaScript, which I think is
really unique as well.
So look through that, try it
out, provide us your feedback
and we'll continue finding ways
to support more of these
open-source libraries.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
Underscore is--
I really like this.
Especially coming from a
language like Python or Ruby,
you're used to having an each
iterator or you're used to
lambdas or you're used to other
craziness like that.
It's not crazy.
It's cool stuff.
And when you come to JavaScript,
JavaScript has a
lot of really good properties.
It's also that the default data
types they tend to be
limited, right?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
IKAI LAN: I don't know if you
guys ever worked with this one
library called Prototype.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Mm-hm, Yep.
IKAI LAN: Prototype, back in the
day, they thought the best
approach was to go ahead and add
all these methods to array
and all that.
And it just made everything
go crazy.
So I think that's kind of--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Not
very compatible.
IKAI LAN: --fallen out of favor,
which is just extending
the base object.
So something like Underscore
just wraps it instead.
And I think we're seeing this
trend more of composition over
inheritance.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Did you
just start a debate?
IKAI LAN: Yeah, I did.
There's only a few minutes left,
so I really shouldn't.
I think there's no debate.
I think wrap things,
just wrap things.
Don't inherit.
Inheritance is bad.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And then
there was another one
from a guest post.
Actually, I forget his name.
Tom.
One of the Googlers that ended
up using Apps Script for a
personal project around an
auction house being able to
track the bids and then
following up with people.
A really interesting use case.
That one actually comes
with a video.
Go check it out, see what the
interesting ways people are
using Apps Script.
IKAI LAN: I remember seeing one
of the guys we met at the
Hackathon who works for
charter schools in LA.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
IKAI LAN: And the thing about
charter schools is--
I'm trying to define what
a charter school is.
It's like a special school?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It's still
a public school, from my
understanding, that has
limited enrollment.
And there oftentimes ends up
being a lottery for admission.
So when you have 30 spots for
a new incoming class, since
they may be in a close-by
neighborhood or they have good
teachers, and people try to
enroll in charter school, and
there's often a lottery involved
in picking who gets
to get those 30 slots.
IKAI LAN: Right.
And the problem they were
trying to solve--
again, try to look at things
from a problem perspective--
was that you have hundreds of
thousands of entries, but he's
got to pull stuff out
of a hat, right?
And that used to be the old way
of doing it, pull stuff
out of a hat.
But with hundreds of entries,
it's like, oh, my goodness,
this is insane.
So instead, he's using Google
Forms to submit something.
This all goes into a
spreadsheet, and he has a
custom menu that goes ahead
and just randomly starts
picking people out, saying,
hey, you're lucky.
You get to go to
charter school.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And then showing
a trailing list on a
big monitor plugged into a
laptop showing stuff from
Google Spreadsheets
in a nice UI.
IKAI LAN: A little
bit of theatrics.
Little bit of pop-up, here's
your name, "you are" tribute.
All right.
Why don't we move
into some Q&A?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
Let's see here.
Go to Moderator.
IKAI LAN: I looked at this a
little bit before the show,
and a common theme here is that
we've got a good amount
of what we call feature
requests.
I've tried to answer these
in the comments.
For instance, I'm looking at
some of these questions, and
some things like,
for instance--
whoa, some people are adding
some stuff in here.
People are adding
questions live.
That's not a bad thing.
There's your pop-up calendar.
For instance, there was
one I saw over here.
"Can we use scripts in
spreadsheets on mobile devices
without desktop use?" Well,
there's nothing to
announce at this time.
And that's a very,
very new product.
We definitely--
we've been saying mobile
first, mobile first.
I think we should start
putting our money
where our mouth is.
But yes, that's something that
we're thinking about.
We're always thinking about
these things, but we really
don't have anything to announce
at this time.
So don't wait for that.
Things you can do are, you can
build a web UI, and you can
access that via a
mobile phone.
Of course, you're doing it
through your browser.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: In fact, the
blog post that I mentioned,
they actually showcase
the tablets there.
IKAI LAN: Cool.
Cool.
Very cool.
Yeah, you're right,
the tablet stuff.
I remember that post now.
There's a few questions here
I wanted to get to first.
There were two I wanted
to answer on the show.
One was-- whoa!
There's a lot of stuff here.
People are adding stuff live.
There are two.
One is, "What's the difference
between using Spreadsheets,
using ScriptDb, and using Fusion
Tables?" So let's start
with each of these,
one by one.
Fusion Tables is--
it's a Google product that
allows you to use geodata and
create these really beautiful
overlays and maps using this
geodata that you can visualize
things going
on, locations and--
OK, you can tell that I'm not
really an expert on Fusion
Tables, but I used to
sit next to one.
So I always just kind
of overhear things
they used to say.
And you can do things like, you
can do a lot of the stuff
that you could do with
the maps API--
maps service--
in that you can do some
geocoding, you could do
bounding box queries.
Bounding Box would be something
like show me
everything within a 5-mile
radius of this point.
And you can just do
querying on this.
So if you're building a service
that involves map
points, points of interest, you
probably want to look at
something like Fusion Tables.
It's going to serve your
needs really well.
Now, on the other hand, this
leaves Spreadsheets and
ScriptDb, when to use one,
when to use the other.
I've been using Spreadsheets
a lot these last few days,
mostly because you get
a couple of benefits.
You get a built-in UI.
You get a ton of features.
You get sorting, filtering.
You can add charts
very easily.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Versioning.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
You get versioning?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Versioning.
IKAI LAN: Right, right.
I actually never check
the version.
Because there's too
many edits.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It does become
a lot of versions.
IKAI LAN: But Spreadsheets
has a very nice UI.
Now again, the downside is
something I mentioned earlier,
which is, because it has UI, if
you give it to people, you
give them a chance to
really break things.
So that's Spreadsheets.
ScriptDb, on the other hand,
is kind of neat, because
ScriptDb is, if you have a
single instance of a script,
you have a global ScriptDb
instance that's shared for all
users of the script.
Now, you might be asking, why
would I want to do this?
You can technically also do this
via Spreadsheets if you
open a spreadsheet via ID.
The difference is that there's
no UI for ScriptDb.
The filter semantics and the
objects you can save in
ScriptDb tend to be a little
bit more robust.
They look closer to JavaScript
objects.
And you've got a little
bit better
programmatic query language.
Like you can say show me all
the people that have an age
greater than 45.
And that's much easier in
ScriptDb, whereas if you were
to do this in--
I think you should be able to
filter in Spreadsheets but
it's not quite as intuitive--
you get a few other
things in ScriptDb
that are kind of neat.
But again, also appending to
Spreadsheets, you pretty much
only can append in
a row format.
With ScriptDb, you can actually
have embedded objects.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
And they can be jagged.
So one object can look
in one shape.
Another object could be
completely different.
And then you can actually have
them all in the same bucket.
So it gives you a lot more
capability as far as the type
of things you store.
IKAI LAN: Right.
The only thing about storing
objects of different types and
different shapes is that,
try to keep them fairly
consistent.
Now, I don't like it when
it's too rigid.
But if you keep it consistent,
like you have
three or four types--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: For indexing.
IKAI LAN: --in your program,
it's going to be that crazy.
If every single object that
you store looks totally
different, you're not going
to be able to do anything.
You're going to drive
yourself nuts.
So I think those are a lot
of the main differences.
Anything else you want to add?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah,
so I think--
IKAI LAN: I feel like I'm
missing something.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: No, it's a
great question, really.
Because I find myself
using both.
The question I ask myself is
what's the volume of data?
If it's just maybe a hundred--
IKAI LAN: That's a good point.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: --couple hundred
rows of data, and I'm
mostly just appending very
tabular-looking data,
Spreadsheets is fine.
But if I need to query something
based on various
filters, or if I don't know
ahead of time if there's going
to be nested objects and things
like that, I usually
tend to go with ScriptDb, also
because it can store thousands
of records.
The size limits there is based
on the total bytes rather the
number of records.
So those are the two things
that I ask for is, am I
querying a lot?
And am I just appending?
Updates are a pain with
Spreadsheets as well, because
you have to--
IKAI LAN: They are
kind of annoying.
The thing about Spreadsheets and
ScriptDb to be aware of is
that the filtering options
only go so far.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
IKAI LAN: So if you're working
with a relatively small number
of objects-- and when I say
relatively small, I'd say a
couple hundred, maybe even
a couple thousand--
instead of trying to build
these incredibly complex
filters, it's sometimes easier
just to create something like
an array and just loop over
every single object and say
doesn't match, doesn't
match, doesn't match.
This also makes your code in
some instances easier to test
and a little bit more robust.
So it just depends on what
your specific needs are.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And then there's
actually a third
service besides Fusion
Tables called JDBC.
So in fact, we have
Cloud SQL as well.
So if you have hundreds of
thousands of rows and are used
to a relational database
querying mechanism through
SQL, we actually have an answer
for that as well.
So depending on your background
and if tabular data
is the way to go for you, that
might be another option.
And you can get a Cloud SQL
instance now for free up until
June, I think, for
testing purposes.
IKAI LAN: Right.
And I think you've got a
certain amount of data.
I don't remember what
the data limit is.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And I just saw
one up for testing myself, and
it was actually fairly pain
free, so try it out.
IKAI LAN: Pain free.
You kind of made up a word
between pain free and painful.
It was kind of funny.
Yeah, it is.
But he is right, though.
What you want to do is
you want to go to the
Google API's console.
And you search for that
by going to Google.
Search for Google API's console
is the easiest way.
I never remember the exact
URL for things anymore.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Just search
for everything.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It's a good
thing we have one.
IKAI LAN: That's just
how things are done.
Yep.
Good thing, too.
So, yeah.
Look for that, and you'll be
able to enable Cloud SQL and
start talking to it.
We've got some samples
on developers.googl
e.com/apps-script.
Look there in the tutorials for
how to talk to Cloud SQL.
I wanted to answer one more
question before the show ends.
It's a question from--
hold on.
It's the one about
working with UIs.
Let me see.
This thing.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Did you go
to the next page, maybe?
IKAI LAN: It could be.
Anyway, the question was
something along the lines of,
when I'm working with a UI app,
it used to be that when
there was an error, it would
show the error in the
Spreadsheets or the UI
App or whatever.
And now it doesn't
do it anymore.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Ah.
There's the question.
From Lenny.
IKAI LAN: From Lenny
in Louisiana.
"When an error occurs from UI,
it's just generic error now."
We'll look into this.
I'm not sure--
we should find out if this is
what we intended to do.
I'm not sure if it was.
It says, "Before it
used to give you
the line of the problem.
And for a novice scripter like
myself, that was a huge
advantage."
So I've been working with UIs
a lot these last few days.
And when UIs start to get a
little more complex, there's
something called the model
view presenter pattern.
I'm not going to overly
advocate it.
But the idea is that in code
that you use to build the UI,
try to make this as simple
as possible.
And what you do is, you want
to abstract out some more
complex bits into these
functions that can run without
UI components.
So an example is, this thing
I'm building for URL
shortening, for instance.
I have a UI that pops up,
just asks you for a
URL and some options.
It has a place that calls
a URL shortener.
Now, in the beginning, I just
tested it as is, where I put
all the code in one function,
built the UI, built the
handler, whatever.
And I was testing it like
running the code in the UI,
pushing the buttons, seeing
if it worked.
And after a while this
got too hard.
So instead, I took the URL
shortening part, which isn't
that complex, but there
was a bug there.
I extracted it out into
its own function.
I wrote a quick function
called test.
And I did all my testing and
debugging within the scope of
the script editor.
Now, this gets you most
of the way there.
What it doesn't really help you
do is debug issues with
the UI itself.
So that's going to
be problematic.
But for the most part, you can
save yourself a lot of pain by
doing as much of your
development in the script
editor as possible.
One of the feature requests that
we've seen from people is
give me a way to
do unit tests.
Unit tests are these things
that, you write code that
validates whether your code
is working or not.
Like right now, there are
different ways you could fake
it out in Apps Script, but
there's no real, always be
running this and tell
me what's failing.
I think that'd be really
cool feature.
But again, we don't
have anything to
announce about this.
But that's one thing you want to
do is try to do as much of
your coding within the script
editor as possible and at the
last second link it
up with your UI.
Now, this isn't always possible,
and when your UIs
get complex, it just
isn't possible.
But try to hold off that pain
as long as possible.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Decouple.
IKAI LAN: Right.
And this is true not just in
Apps Script, but in anything,
whether it's Google Web Toolkit,
whether you're
building an HTML service,
just anything.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
Think we're up on time?
IKAI LAN: I think we
are up on time.
So we're sorry if we didn't get
around to your question.
I've tried to answer them
in the comments.
A lot of these are
feature requests.
So go ahead and file
one with us.
They're under Apps
Script issues.
You could search for that in
Google, and it should be one
of the first results.
Or any search engine.
Ikai's Custom Search Engine
dot com, which
doesn't exist yet.
Don't try going there.
You'll be able to find these
issues, create a feature
request, and this way, we can
track it when we're looking at
what the backlog is.
And if you see anything that's
really important
to you, star it.
Don't overly star, because it's
the whole crying wolf
thing, and we won't know
what's important.
So star the issues that
are important to you.
Again, we're sorry for the
issues with the Hangout for
those of you that wanted
to jump in live.
Apologies.
We will try to have it working
before the next show.
And anything else we have to
announce before we jump off?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I think
that's it for now.
IKAI LAN: OK.
Again, the two announcements
we did at the
beginning of the show.
I'm just going to remind
you guys again.
Arun's doing a show about how to
integrate Apps Script with
Salesforce tomorrow, so
definitely jump on if you can.
If not, we're posting to
YouTube.com/googledevelopers.
That's the channel of everything
that we're doing.
And if you want to find Apps
Script specific videos, you
can search for Apps
Script videos.
And we have a page that we try
to update periodically with
all the newest videos, including
"Office Hours" and
special "Google Developer
Live" shows.
And next Tuesday, I'm doing an
introductory show about triggers.
So Salesforce, triggers.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I'm sure
there'll be more.
IKAI LAN: Yep.
And we'll be doing
a lot more, too.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank
you very much.
IKAI LAN: Thank you guys very
much, and we'll see
you at the next show.
[MUSIC PLAYING]